in Rockland County New York they've
reached crisis point a measles outbreak
19 years after it was officially
eliminated from the US this began with
the introduction of the measles virus
into the county by 7 different travelers
who were not vaccinated and they came
from Israel and there were some holiday
time it was a lot of families visiting
one another and it could spread through
the community of to those who were not
vaccinated we're not immune hospitals
are now offering free vaccinations not
enough people having them health
officials have taken drastic action I am
today declaring a countywide state of
emergency effective at the stroke of
midnight tonight March 27th anyone who
is under 18 years of age and is on
vaccinated against the measles we bought
from public places until the declaration
expires in 30 days or until they receive
at least their first shot of MMR but
this is home to a large ultra-orthodox
Jewish community and some local leaders
say fanning young unvaccinated people
from areas is already alienating them it
opens the door for people who are bigots
or interested in profiling people opens
the door for that kind of behavior and
that's from the Jewish Federations
perspective that's our concern you think
people will be stigmatized we're already
seeing it we're already seeing it more
than 150 people have caught the virus so
far and local authorities say that this
department store is one of the places
where residents may have been exposed
health officials say that anti-vaccine
advocates have been sowing distrust
handing out leaflets and spreading the
debunked theory that MMR causes autism
an insular population like this one that
worships and travels together is
especially vulnerable but across America
there's been a rise in parents objecting
to vaccinations but philosophical or
religious reasons or because they
believe discouraged
information the virus hasn't changed its
human behavior that has madelia Lynch
Sky News Rockland County you know